we are now only 24 days away from
september 14th which is the expected
date for apple's september event where
we will 100 be getting a new apple watch
and we know that for sure because apple
has released a new watch in september
every single year since 2016. and if you
look at youtube most videos on apple
watch series 7 leaks assume that it's
getting a full redesign but there's
actually some evidence that points to no
redesign happening this year which would
be very disappointing but it's
definitely a possibility so what i'm
gonna do in this video is give you guys
all the evidence and reasoning for both
of those scenarios using common sense
and very recent leaks and rumors from
reliable sources and before we begin i
want to remind you guys of the apple
watch update situation over the past
couple of years because it's going to be
very important for this video back in
2018 apple finally gave the watch a full
redesign with the series 4 giving it a
much larger display with rounded corners
just like apple gave the iphone 10 a
year before that and the series 4 also
came with an awesome looking rear sensor
array as well but ever since then the
apple watch updates have been quite a
bit disappointing in 2019 the series 5
simply got a boost in storage and it
added an always-on display and that's
basically it and because of that many
people stuck to the series 4 and then
last year apple revealed the new series
6 and the two standout features were the
red and blue color options as well as
the new blood oxygen sensor of course
there were also small updates like the
faster s6 chip they're brighter always
on display the always-on altimeter for
elevation tracking and the new u1 ultra
wideband chip but in reality none of
those new updates really changed that
much for regular apple watch users which
was again pretty disappointing and now
we're expecting the series 7 in less
than a month and the big question is
this will apple finally redesign the
apple watch again or will they hold off
for just one more year and we're gonna
answer that question in this video so
let's go ahead and start off with the
redesigned scenario by looking into all
the evidence that points to this
happening of course back in may john
prosser revealed renders of a redesigned
apple watch which look absolutely
fantastic matching up to the design of
the iphone 12 lineup which makes perfect
sense the renders even include a new
layout for the speakers featuring two
thin and long strips on the side
and john says it's a weird change but
that's exactly what he saw on the leaked
cad files and just the other day those
actual cad files that john used were
leaked by
91mobiles.com showing basically the same
design that john's render showed off
even down to those new speaker slots
which makes his leak from back in may
seem totally legit and just by looking
at those cad files it seems like the
current apple watch bands will fully
support this new apple watch design
which makes it even better now going
back to a report from mark german in
march he said that apple is considering
a new apple watch model with a rugged
casing aimed at athletes which would be
perfect to launch alongside the
redesigned watch and then in june mark
reported that we should expect updated
screens and performance this year and
then new functions next year he also
mentioned that we should expect better
wireless connectivity and new ultra wide
band tech which will probably be the
youtube chat and then finally just a few
days ago mark reported that he expects a
bit of a redesign on the apple watch
with flatter displays and updated screen
technology using a new lamination
technique to get the display closer to
the cover glass now in my mind if
they're going to be redesigning the
display why not also redesign the whole
body as well all in one foul swoop which
makes more sense to me on top of that we
got a recent report showing that the
titanium apple watch series 6 models are
now entirely unavailable which would
only make sense if apple is planning to
redesign the body so that those titanium
casings wouldn't be able to be used for
the series 7. but then again there's
also the small possibility that apple
could be completely ditching titanium
for good but it just doesn't seem likely
since it's a fairly new option so
overall that's most of the evidence we
have for the apple watch series 7 to get
the full redesign next month especially
since 91mobiles.com is so confident that
it's the series 7. and now let's get
into the pieces of evidence that point
to the redesign not happening until next
year first off when john prosser
revealed the apple watch redesigned
renders back in may he said that his
source didn't tell him whether this was
the series 7 or not so it was totally
possible that the renders could be of
the series 8. on top of that in mark
german's june 14th report he mentioned
that the new extreme sports models
aren't planned until next year and he
believes that those models will be more
rugged by giving the apple watch a
rubberized casing making it more
resistant to damage and in reality the
easiest way to implement the rubber
casing in an effective manner would be
if the design had flat sides and a flat
display just like john prosser showed
off allowing apple to give the casing a
raised edge or lip to help it avoid
display glass damage and going even
deeper and german's report from a few
days ago
he mentioned that the apple watch is
getting a bit of a redesign which is odd
because when he talks about other
products like the ipad mini 6 he claims
that it'll be getting a full redesign
but not this time so there is a chance
that apple could hold off on the
redesign until next year when they also
reveal the new rugged models and the
really weird thing is that mark german
said that the series seven will be a bit
thicker than the series six and this
detail is very important because the
leaked cad files by 91 mobiles claim
that the redesigned watch will be 1.7
millimeters thinner which goes against
what mark german said about it actually
being a bit thicker so if apple does
delay the redesign
the big question is what will apple do
to the series 7 to make it a worthwhile
upgrade well this brings us to a very
old report from the economic daily news
back in 2019 claiming the apple will
switch from oled to micro led displays
in the apple watch as soon as 2020 which
obviously didn't happen so what if the
series 7 is finally getting this huge
display upgrade without getting a full
redesign yet if you think about it a new
micro led display would go perfectly in
line with mark german's report of a new
flatter display with upgraded screen
technology with thinner bezels and a new
lamination technique and on top of that
micro led will probably also improve
battery life at the same time since it's
going to be more efficient and going
even further mark said that the series 7
will get a new s7 chip no matter what
and it'll be the first five nanometer
apple watch chip compared to the s6
which is built on the seven nanometer
process this is also going to be a huge
improvement for performance while also
improving efficiency which is gonna lead
to a further jump in battery life now
because of all of those battery life
gains from the new chip and the new
display apple has more room to work with
to enable better features like
potentially 5g connectivity while
keeping the overall battery life the
same as it was before and since mark
german mentioned that the series 7 is
getting a bit thicker there's a chance
that apple is putting in an even bigger
battery to help them enable 5g because
the new display itself should
technically make it thinner not thicker
now alongside the new chip we should
also expect bluetooth 5.2 to match up to
the new iphone 13 and the new airpods 3.
there's also a chance that we could see
the s7 chip get 2 gigs of ram instead of
one and we might even get wi-fi 6e to
match up with the iphone 13 series
because it's more efficient and it helps
save battery life all of these things
together could be a big enough deal that
apple could potentially delay the full
redesign that john prosser showed off
until next year and there you guys go
that's all the evidence and reasoning
for the scenario where we do not get a
full redesign this year and now let me
finally finish off with which of these
scenarios i think is more likely and why
i honestly think that it makes more
sense for the redesign to actually come
on this year's series 7 for a few
different reasons first off since the
series 4 got a redesign the year after
the iphone 10 did it kind of makes sense
for the series 7 to get a redesign right
now because the iphone 12 was fully
redesigned last year which was a very
good point that zone of tech brought up
in his recent video and to me i don't
think apple would want the watch to
stick to the old design while the iphone
will be getting the new flat design for
the second year in a row on top of that
john prosser was able to get his hands
on those cad files way back in may so if
they were actually for next year's
series 8 that would have been very
unrealistic for him to get his hands on
them so early and one important detail
to mention is that 91 mobiles leaked
those cad files while also claiming that
they're for the series seven so their
confidence shows that they probably know
for sure that it's for the series 7 and
not for the 8. going deeper mark german
said we should expect new functions like
sensors to come next year so it wouldn't
make sense for apple to update both the
design and the sensors at one time next
year which is why the redesign should
probably come this year and finally
german is usually pretty cautious with
his rumors which is why he said it's
getting a bit of a redesign without
calling it a full redesign so just in
case the display gets updated alone he
would still be correct but in my opinion
it makes sense to redesign both the
display and the body at the same time
and then next year apple is going to
bring out the new functions and sensors
alongside the new rugged model to help
boost sales now if you totally disagree
with my point of view go ahead and
comment your thoughts down below but if
you enjoyed the video click that circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one definitely check out one of
those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]